[Music]
chopsticks
[Music]
hey there i'm mark ellison if you were
wishing for another episode of rt
essentials consider it granted today
we'll be talking about your classic
make-a-wish films where one straight
thought spoken out loud can be enough to
turn toys into real boys real boys into
adult men moms into their angsty teen
daughters and said daughters into their
moms wow just like every girl's dream
but for every dream deal that's too good
to be true there's gonna be a catch and
for some reason it's probably gonna come
in the form of judy greer hey look i
don't make the magic wishing rules
around here i'm just an antique fortune
telling machine messenger you can find
down by the boardwalk no matter what
dreams may come true movies about magic
wishes all share a similar message it's
always better to be yourself than to be
anyone else and that includes your own
mother the actual lord god or even a 30
year old senior editor for poise your
favorite fashion magazine i know hard to
believe well don't just take my word for
it sit back relax and get ready to see
for yourself in this all-new episode of
rt essentials the best wish fulfillment
movie
freaky friday now girls you're not
children any longer i feel that i can
speak with you as adults
i think you're intelligent enough to
grasp exactly what i have to say to you
right now
what is this
it's your usual rum raisin banana split
breakfast
figures
what else with a junk food junkie for
breakfast
that is about the most revolting
concoction i've ever put inside my mouth
so the idea of waking up as your mother
seems less like wish fulfillment more
like a depressing inevitability if not
outright body horror gary nelson's 1976
freaky friday is still considered the og
body swap movie starring a young jody
foster as high school student annabelle
and barbara harris as her mother ellen
at least until they both simultaneously
wish to be the other with hilarity
ensuing freaky friday earned three
golden globe nominations one for the
song i'd like to be you for a day and
two for best actress in a musical or
comedy technically since they played
each other they were nominated for the
same role freaky friday has proved so
popular that it's been remade three
times by disney a tv movie starring
shelley long hey from cheers and gabby
hoffman the 2003 lindsay lohan and jamie
lee curtis remake and a 2018 disney
channel musical starring cozy zulsdorf
and heidi blickenstaff who i've just
been informed are actual actors and not
backup singers for abba if it had not
been for jody foster's mom freaky friday
may have never happened and instead we'd
be living in an alternate universe where
the silence of the lambs actress was our
princess leia that's right george lucas
wanted her for the part when casting
star wars episode 4 a new hope but her
mother opted to honor foster's contract
with disney instead the irony not being
lost on those of us living in the future
where being in a star wars movie
actually counts towards your disney
credit freaky friday helped kick-start
the genre of body-swapping films that
really flourished in the 1980s you've
got your like father-like sons your
dream a little dreams vice verses and
even your all of me where instead of
swapping places with someone married to
her own father
a bedridden lily tomlin ends up in the
body of her warrior played by steve
martin none of the future spawns would
attempt to stick the same landing as
freaky friday since by the 80s a
climactic water skiing incident would
already be known
as jumping the shark
bruce almighty hello
i need your help
flap on
clap on
well hello there bruce almighty
not as easy as it looks is it son
this god business bruce almighty aimed
higher in terms of wish fulfillment if
you were going to trade places with
someone maybe look outside your
immediate family and go with god
literally the titular character played
by jim carrey gets to take on the powers
of the great almighty deity played by
morgan freeman from whom he also
unintentionally inherits the gig's heavy
responsibilities and honestly living in
a post spider-man early aughts bruce
only has himself to blame for not
reading the entire fine print and
choosing to focus on the immediate perks
like being able to part tomato soup
undermine steve carell at work and have
monkeys fly out of people's butts you
know the run-of-the-mill god stuff if
you catch a familiar face for two and
bruce almighty no you're not going crazy
that is the same monkey from the movie
outbreak probably best known for playing
marcel and friends alongside bruce
almighty co-star jennifer aniston he was
comfortable with the film's lead as well
having worked with jim carrey on both
ace ventura films but you know what they
say about hollywood it's all about who
you fling pooh at this axiom was also
true for director tom shadiak who had
collaborated with carrie first on ace
ventura pet detective and liar wire the
latter of which we'll be talking about a
little bit later but i do want to give
honorable mention to ace ventura since
it contributed to the wish fulfillment
of having jim carrey's comedy career
back in 1994. jack nicholson and robert
de niro were among two of the other
actors originally approached about
playing god in the film probably best
that didn't pan out or else we might
have a scene where bruce is praying and
god shows up saying you talking to me
ferris big thank you
brennan
baskin
what is this payday
hey whoa where's mine
for 187
yeah
[ __ ] they really screw you don't they
who is a kid never dreamed about
adulthood with its seeming total lack of
accountability having ice cream for
breakfast sleeping until two in the
afternoon wearing pajamas 24 7. i do all
those things yes it's all about
childhood dreams being easily achievable
as a grown-up depressed freelancer penny
marshall's 1988 hit big was the proof of
concept for many of us who grew up
thinking we could land jobs by getting
good at the giant keyboard at fao
schwartz when pre-teen josh gets his one
wish of the boardwalk thanks to a
mechanical genie he wakes up the next
day to find himself in the body of a
young tom hanks which isn't the
immediate dream it appears to be unable
to go home he's forced to fend for
himself in the big city where he's
pretty much immediately employed by a
toy company run by robert loggia thanks
to his innate child's ability to know
the notes from chopsticks and yes that
is hanks and logia in the infamous fao
scene after noticing two guys
approximating their heights and age
hanging out during rehearsal the actors
realized they'd be replaced by stunt
doubles if they weren't able to nail the
choreography and they vowed to get the
number right themselves hey having your
own stunt double waiting in the wings
counts for its own kind of wish
fulfillment in my book and though
hanks's boyish charm made him an obvious
for his choice for the role his shooting
schedule forced him to pass on big the
amount of actors that passed on the role
thereafter are staggering judge reinhold
john travolta steve guttenberg robert
williams albert brooks and gary busey
were just a few of the names approached
about taking the part really gary that's
the movie i want to see the studios
didn't bite until a certain name came
along a guy who may have played god once
had it not been for morgan freeman
that's right robert de niro was locked
and ready to go for big but his demand
for a six million dollar payday cost
from the part especially when hanks
freed up some time and took the role for
only two million smack big would go on
to be hanks's first best actor oscar
nomination and minted penny marshall as
the first female director to have a film
make over 100 million dollars you know
what uh brb i gotta go talk to my man's
altar about making some of my wishes
come true oh wait he already did with
the whole ice cream thing bedazzled
promise not to tell anyone
okay
cross your heart and hope to die
[Music]
i'm the devil
okay
the devil's in the details when it comes
to bedazzle harold ramus's y2k remake of
the peter cook and dudley moore comedy
that set faust in 1960's london but
while making a deal with the devil is a
tale as old as time or at least the old
testament there is a modern twist when
meek nebbish computer programmer elliott
rogers played by the great brendan
fraser is approached by beelzebub with
an offer to trade seven wishes for his
immortal soul classic lord of darkness
stuff the demon appears as elizabeth
hurley fellas i'm obligated by law to
throw in one does that make you honey
baby because she's got actual horns
elliot's wishes go predictably awry each
scenario reimagines elliot his crush and
co-workers in different alternate
realities living out some monkey's paw
version of what he had asked for but
ultimately it wasn't frazier's heavily
marketed impression of dennis rodman
that stole the show instead millions of
boys across the world had their wish
granted by elizabeth hurley's wardrobe
in bedazzled which no expenses were
spared costume designer dina appel did
the lord's work here collaborating with
hurley on 19 different outfits that fit
satan's pension for little black and red
dresses for that many get-ups appel had
to get creative one was a dyed version
of an ensemble she put hurley in for
austin powers and the infamous
schoolgirl look that came from harley's
own wardrobe so yeah basically hurley
was just asking america do i make it all
right i already did that joke
harold rambus is no stranger to the wish
granting genre movies like groundhog day
and dave all explore the downside of
being stuck in extraordinary
circumstances whether that's getting to
play president or infinitely looping
through one single holiday in 1998 when
ghostbusters 3 fell through ramus
expressed interest in this project and
found himself in a devil of a pickle the
timing conflicted with his latest
project galaxy quest and he ultimately
had to drop out of directing that movie
in order to make bedazzle while he did
remain on galaxy quest as a producer it
does prove sometimes you just got to
sell your soul for art
am i right
anybody
liar wire
is it good for you
[Music]
i've had better
1997's liar liar it's not your typical
wish fulfillment movie because jim
carrey's character fletcher reed doesn't
exactly start the film praying for a big
change in his life instead it's his
son's birthday wish that forces the
chronically fitting father to speak the
whole truth for an entire day and
considering that fletcher is a
sleazeball lawyer in the middle of a
career-defining divorce trial the timing
just couldn't be worse blaire lyra
marked a departure for carrie who had
made a name for himself in raunchy and
outrageous comedies like dumb and dumber
the mask and aceventura which had all
hit theaters only three years prior and
teaming up again with ace ventura
director tom shadyac carrie went from
wildly buffoonish to
i mean look it's jim carrey he's still
pretty manic in this one but we also get
that he's a workaholic caught up in a
bizarre birthday spell instead of being
an entire human cartoon kerry took the
role immediately after reading the
script delighted to finally play a quote
normal person and you best believe this
was his motivation as he turned down the
role of austin powers to star in the
family friendly flick but look a fish
gotta swim a bird's gotta fly and jim
carrey's gotta be a human puppet made
out of bouncy rubber the scene at which
he hurled himself around the courtroom
bathroom beating himself up required no
extra sound editing every whap you hear
are the real noises caused by jim carrey
slamming himself against various pieces
of set for you die hard carry heads
there's even an easter egg in the movie
that alludes to the actor's comedic
roots in the aftermath of the big plane
chase scene eagle-eyed viewers can spot
fire marshall bill one of carrie's
characters from his days on a living
color in the background doing crowd
control alrighty then guess that was
carrie's version of being subtle
it's a wonderful life
help me clarence
get me back
get me back i don't care what happens to
me
get me back to my wife and kids
happy clarence please
please
i want to live again
i want to live again it's a wonderful
life frank's s tear in wish fulfillment
movies and with good reason in frank
capper's 1949 classic jimmy stewart
plays george bailey a man at the end of
his robe who's given a second chance at
life or at least to see what the world
would look like without his good deeds
thanks to his guardian angel whose real
name is clarence in the end the down on
his leg banker avoids jail time when the
town comes together to pitch in to help
pay off his debts as a subscriber to
next door i'm going to say the whole
angelic intervention by a personalized
what-if episode is the lesser of these
two miracles really they all pitched in
for george bailey okay a good hollywood
rule of thumb is that increasing the
number of writers on any project will
have a directly inversely proportionate
effect to its success doesn't matter if
it's james mangle directing a movie with
two of the world's most bankable stars
when the wga was forced to remove 11 of
the 12 writing credits for night and day
you know it's gonna bomb
it's a wonderful life managed to be the
exception with several legendary
hollywood scribes ending up contributing
to the script including dorothy parker
and dalton trumbo oh so that's why the
movie's so anti-big banking is resolved
with socialism i kid while considered a
classic by today's standards life bombed
in theaters on its initial release it
didn't gain the cult holiday status it
enjoys today until 1974 when the film's
copyright expired making wonderful
public domain in the subsequent decades
that followed capra's film became tv
network's go-to stocking stuffer filling
in the time slots to cover for the lack
of original programming during the
holidays man i guess it's lucky it came
out before a christmas story now we all
love and cherish it's a wonderful life
so don't you ever feel guilty for
tearing up at the sound of a bell
ringing or a lively rendition of buffalo
girls won't you come out tonight stars
jimmy stewart and donna reed both
considered it their favorite film while
capper cited it as the greatest
achievement of his career 13 going on
30. and speaking of hut
mr heidi behind you is totally scamming
on you right now
[Music]
he is not
he's totally cute should i go talk to
him you're not married
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
2004's 13 going on 30 is another example
of the birthday wish fulfillment
subgenre jenna rank is a geeky teen in
1994 when she's humiliated by her
friends during her 13th birthday locked
in a closet jenna wishes that she could
fast forward and wake up as the 30 year
old magazine editor she's dreamt of
being one day well she gets her wish and
the added bonus is that she wakes up in
jennifer garner's body but unlike some
other examples on this list jenna's path
to adulthood was not overnight instead
her consciousness had been zapped
forward a decade ignore all the
authority metaphysical implications
about fatalism and free will and you're
left with a super fun rom-com that
tapped into a generation of female fans
desire for autonomy success and material
luxuries 13 going on 30 features a
number of performances by future mcu
actors besides that big hulking green
guy is a grown-up version of jenna's shy
crush there's andy circus as her boss at
the fashion magazine boys judy greer as
her backstabbing childhood bestie turned
assistant editor and even a blink and
you'll miss it cameo from a young
captain marvel with brie larson in a
non-speaking role as one of the mean
girls who torments jenna in the 1990s
the irony here is that jennifer garner
herself has never been in an mcu movie
despite starring in both marvel's
daredevil and elektra can we get jen
into something please to prepare for the
role garner spent a lot of time hanging
out with her teenage counterpart krista
b allen and powder so impressive that
she would tap her again to play her
younger self five years later in ghosts
of girlfriend's past in october fans
rejoiced on social media as allen
officially turned 30 while the rest of
us frantically googled the movie's
release date in the hopes that we'd read
the fact wrong are we really that old
this movie didn't come about it oh god
it did 2004 was that long ago already
pinocchio
hey
you laugh like a donkey
did that come out of me
[Music]
oh
huh
what's going on
pinocchio is the 1940 disney classic
about a sentient marionette card by a
lonely old man and brought to life by a
benevolent deity known as the blue fairy
the blue fairy the one that dangles the
prospect of becoming a real boy over the
doll's head to you know keep him good
and what seems like overkill unless you
seriously considered that the doll you
just brought to life is uh hello chucky
the fairy contours to other fail-safes
in pinocchio's morality clause giving
him a nose that grows larger with every
lie he tells and appointing a bug named
jiminy cricket to act as an ethics
advisor to a child's toy maybe
unsurprisingly pinocchio initially began
as an unlikable protagonist a bratty
wooden child who needed jiminy cricket's
constant lecturing to stay honest
halfway through the animation process
walt disney halted production to retold
the story and make pinocchio a little
more tolerable though i think we'd all
like to see the cut where the title
character is just smoking and cursing up
a storm from a mouth situated underneath
a serrano de bergerac linked schnoz the
film bombed upon it's really why did all
these movies bomb initially though not
because it's literally too traumatic to
show children but because of the
turbulence caused by the lead-up to
world war ii when overseas markets were
cut off from american distribution
despite these significant hurdles
pinocchio went on to become the first
animated film to win an academy award in
a competitive category earn a profit
during release and get a 100 percent
certified fresh rating from our own
tomato and in a creepy twist the real
puppet used as the model for pinocchio
went missing after the film was
completed and stayed gone for over 50
years until it was discovered in a
basement cabinet at disney wow the
divergent life of toys not everybody
gets to be buzz and woody and have
adventures some of them just take a nap
in a cabinet for 50 years
cinderella there's nothing left to
believe in
nothing
nothing my dear
oh now you don't really mean that oh but
i do nonsense child
if you'd lost all your faith i couldn't
be here
and here i am
oh it's a beautiful dress
did you ever see such a beautiful dress
and look
glass slippers
after tackling the tail of the wooden
boy who couldn't die disney's next big
hit would be the slightly more
conventional wish fulfillment cinderella
in 1950 the original poor girl slipper
strapping her way to the top saga we all
know the tale while being forced to toil
as a servant for her naughty stepmother
and stepsisters cinderella secretly
schemes to attend the royal ball and
dance with the prince cinderella's fairy
godmother arrives to help her with the
glow up but a countdown clock sends her
scurrying into the night leaving behind
a happy accident of misplaced footwear
ultimately cinderella gets her prince
and even the step family comes out okay
in the end since at least they didn't
have to lose large chunks of their heels
and toes as was the case in the original
grim story from which this film was
adapted walt disney's personal favorite
piece of animation came from cinderella
as the godmother transforms cinderella's
tattered rags into a pristine silver
gown but the true magic trick happened
behind the scenes after a decade of box
office duds thanks to world war ii
cinderella was the final gamble walt
disney could make before he went totally
bankrupt to save time and money the
studio shot a majority of the film in
live action first for animators to
replicate later and well the rest is
history literally cinderella brought
disney's golden age of animation to a
close and ushered in a new era where
subsequent films were produced less
artistically and more with an eye
towards commercial and financial success
this changing of the guard was mirrored
by the studio replacing sleeping
beauty's castle for cinderellas as both
the company's logo and flagship location
at the heart of its newest theme park
disney world which opened in 1970.
really i always thought they were the
same castle but apparently cinderella's
abode which again we only really see
once in the film before she lives there
is bigger than her predecessors ooh
that's an idea for a show the real
castle wives of disney little
you went to bed grown and then you woke
up little
but that's for white people because
black people don't have the time i know
what happened i can't even think of what
could possibly happen no no i mean
how did you go from this
to this
regina hall issa rae and mikey day best
known for not being pete davidson on
saturday night live co-star in little
2019's passion project for black-ish
actress marseille martin hall was a tech
mogul who was too busy breaking the
glass ceiling to give her assistant
april the time of day until her wish of
being a kid again the night before a
meeting with her biggest client
backfires and puts her back into a 14
year old body uh here's a good rule of
thumb if you're a high powered executive
maybe don't go making whimsical little
pronouncements with vague wording the
night before your biggest investor comes
to town and if you do just be very very
specific with what kind of tiny wyoming
magic you're in the market for with
little marson who plays hall's younger
self not only pitched the movie to
studios herself but got an executive
producer credit for making it making her
literally the youngest executive
producer in hollywood history and that
leads me to my latest theory that mason
is irl a middle-aged movie producer who
made a wish on a magic theater screen so
they could go back and finance and star
in little prove me wrong somebody proved
me wrong and yes you could be saying to
yourself isn't this just the benjamin
button version of 13 going on 30 which
by the way great reference the movie's
inspiration is actually another film on
this week's list and is hiding in plain
sight of course a movie called little
would be the story of big in reverse
don't feel bad it took me like five
minutes to figure that out i can also
forgive you for forgetting about the
similar premise of 17 again as i'm sure
both zac efron and matthew perry wish
they could well that brings us to the
end of our episode on the best wish
fulfillment in cinema what we didn't
even talk about mr destiny yet jim
belushi renee russo john lovitz uh
here's a final fun fact for you instead
the term wish fulfillment comes from
sigmund freud's
venture feeling which he described as
manifestations of repressed subconscious
desires it's a shame he never got to see
freaky friday because boy
he would've had a field day with that
one
we hope you've enjoyed this episode you
can always check us out at
rottentomatoes.com where we're bringing
you the best in movie and entertainment
news as well as our trusted tomato meter
of critic reviews and audience scores
you've been watching rt essentials i'm
mark ellis and i really wish you'd stick
around because we have some great
programming coming up right after this
and that's adult and kid mark saying
that
[Music]